The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good afternoon.
So in the last week
of this semester,
we will be finishing up
the chapter on coherence.
What we want to continue
to explore today
is the presence of a dark state.
If you have a three
level system, and that's
what we went through
last week, we
will always find one
state which is dark,
which means we fully illuminate
the atom with laser light,
but there is one
state which is not
coupled to the excited state
which does not scatter light,
and therefore is dark.
I showed you that for very
general conditions, if you have
two laser beams
exciting the two states,
there will always be a coherent
superposition of the two
states, which is the dark state.
The dark state is the novel
feature of three level systems,
and I want to show you
different perspectives of it.
We started out by talking
about just the existence
of the dark state.
Then we talked about
dark state transfer.
You can regard, for detuned
light, the dark state
as the lowest energy
state of the system.
And then an adiabatic
theorem tells you
that you can keep
particles in the dark state
even if you change
the laser parameters
and change what state
is now the dark state.
This is the basis of
coherent population transfer,
or the famous STIRAP method.
There is another aspect
of the dark state
which gives us a possibility
of lasing without inversion.
As I reminded you,
lasing has a threshold,
which is inversion that you need
more atoms in the excited state
than in the ground state because
the atoms in the ground state
absorb the laser light
and you want a net gain.
However, if you
have a dark state,
you have a situation where the
atoms do not absorb the laser
light, and therefore, the
conditions for net gain
have changed.
And indeed, lasing without
inversion becomes possible.
I started to explain
to you the way
how lasing without
inversion could come about.
It relies on the fact that
in a three level system,
absorption
destructively interferes
but stimulated emission does
not destructively interfere.
And therefore, you
can have lasing
without inversion in
such three level systems.
I showed you one
possible realization,
and this is about hydrogen
in a DC electric field.
If we mix the 2S and 2P
states with an electric field,
we have this three
level structure.
And for a laser tuned right
in the middle between the two
states, the two amplitudes
for excitation cancel exactly,
and therefore, you have a
zero absorption feature.
However, if you put now a
little bit of population into,
let's say, the upper
state, this upper state
in the wings of its
profile has still
gained for stimulated
emission, and what we get
is lasing without inversion.
Now you say, OK, but
that's a hydrogen atom.
Which atom is really
degenerate between two levels,
and you can split regeneracy
with a static electric field.
Well, you're already an expert
at this point in the course.
If the 2S and 2P state
are widely separated,
well, you add a
photon, and the photon,
which is in resonance
with the 2S and 2P state,
creates, in the dressed
atom picture, degeneracy.
Maybe I should have
shown the P state higher.
The 2S state with one
more photon and the 2P
state with one photon
less have the same energy,
and then you create
exactly this situation.
So therefore, the
way you can realize
that in atoms
other than hydrogen
is use an AC electric field
to mix S and P states.
And I'll show you in five
minutes a little bit more
in detail what I mean by that.
There is a trivial
realization which
I want to mention for
lasing without inversion,
and this would be if
you have a three level
system with an excited
state, two levels, g
and f in the ground state.
You may have an inversion
for the e to g transition.
And therefore,
you can get lasing
because the population in
this state f is not coupled.
This is pretty trivial, but the
more subtle part, of course,
is that we can realize it using
a driven system using a control
laser by creating the same
situation with the bright
and the dark state, and
population in the dark state
is hidden from the light
and does not absorb light.
Let me just indicate that
in both those states,
we would have no
absorption, dark state.
Those examples may raise the
question whether whenever
you have lasing
without inversion,
if you can find a basis where
you have inversion again
between the two levels
which are relevant
and the extra population
is just hidden.
I want to make two
comments about it.
This question is
sometimes discussed
in the literature, sometimes
in a semi-controversial way.
There are two comments about it.
One is when you
start dressing up
your system with laser beams,
you have strong control lasers.
You have two lasers,
omega 1, omega 2.
One is often a
strong control laser
and the other one
is the weak laser
where we want to have lasing.
You have actually a time
dependent system driven
by time dependent fields, and
once you have a time dependent
system, it's no longer clear
what the eigenstates are,
what the populations are,
and what are the coherences.
There is no longer a
unique way to distinguish
what are the eigenstates because
every state is, so to speak,
time dependent
almost by definition.
On the other hand,
I think the example
I gave you with atomic
hydrogen where you just
a little bit of mixing
with an electric field
is an example
where you genuinely
have less population
in the excited state
than you have in
the ground state,
and at least the equation tells
you, even without inversion,
you have a net gain.
So my own understanding
of that situation
is that in many situations,
you can actually reduce it
to a simple picture where you
have simply hidden population
in a dark state, but without any
sort of unnatural definitions,
you may not find that
in some other systems.
Questions about lasing
without inversion?
Nancy?
STUDENT: Is lasing
without inversion
important in lab, as opposed
to lasing with inversion,
or is it more about
teaching us [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: Well, lasing
without inversion
has definitely been
touted as a way
to get lasing deeper
in the UV, to get
lasing for very blue
transitions because when
you want to create inversion--
this actually has been
the problem in creating
x-ray lasers in atomic systems.
If you have larger and
larger energy separation,
spontaneous emission scales
with omega [? cube. ?]
And so therefore, it
becomes harder and harder
to fulfill the
ordinary gain equation.
STUDENT: So in those
cases, even these last two
methods [INAUDIBLE]
because [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: Well, lasing
without inversion
alleviates the requirement
to build a laser,
and so people have
discussed that where
it's really hard to create a
laser in the conventional way,
deep, deep in the blue of the
UV or in the x-ray regime,
that lasing without
inversion may help.
I'm not aware that any
practical development
has emerged from that because
there is a price to be paid,
and that is usually in
the form of coherence.
You need a certain
degree of coherence
in your system to
be able to do that.
It's an idea which is
powerful, but as far as I know,
there was no killer
application of it.
The importance of dark
states is definitely
in slow light, manipulation,
quantum computation,
and concepts of storing
light, and this is
what we want to discuss next.
Actually not next,
but after next.
What I first want to
discuss is another aspect
of the dark state, and
this goes by the name
EIT, electromagnetically
induced transparency.
I can introduce this topic by
a question to Radio Yerevan,
is it possible to send a laser
beam through a brick wall?
And the answer of Radio
Yerevan, if you know the joke,
is always, in principle yes, but
you need another very powerful
laser.
So in an incoherent
way, of course,
a very powerful laser can
drill a hole into the wall
and then the next laser
can go through the wall
without absorption,
but you can be smarter.
If the very powerful
laser through coherence
puts all the atoms in the brick
in the beam pass of the laser
into a coherent
superposition state,
and then they
become a dark state,
then your laser can go
through a brick wall.
So can a laser beam penetrate
an optically thick medium?
And the answer is yes, with
the help of another laser.
Original ideas along those
lines were formulated by Steve
Harris, who has really
pioneered this field,
and he first considered special
auto-ionizing excited states
which couple to--
there were two pathways of
coupling into the continuum,
but later work has
shown that it can
be realized in a lambda system.
Let me talk about this
conceptionally simpler
realization in a three
level lambda system.
Let's assume we have again
our normal three level system
gf and an excited state
which has a width, gamma.
And we want to send a probe
laser through a dense medium,
and it would be completely
absorbed by the resonance
to the excited state.
But now we can have a
strong coupling laser
with a rapid frequency,
omega c, and so if we drive
the system very strongly, we
can create a situation where
the coupling laser does, if
it's strong enough, complete
mixing between the excited
state and the ground state,
and that means if you have two
levels which are completely
mixed, they are split by
the energy or the frequency
of the coupling.
So in other words,
what we obtain is we
have now two states, e
plus f and e minus f.
You know the how you should
read is the following.
You can just assume
for a second the state
f will degenerate with gamma and
then I put in a very strong mix
in between the two.
This is exactly the example
we had with hydrogen
in an electric
field, and then we
get two states which have
both width gamma over 2.
They are strongly
mixed, and the splitting
is nothing else than the matrix
element of the electric field.
But if you don't have
two degenerate states
and we add a photon,
then the photon--
I mentioned it again and again
in addressed atom picture--
creates a degeneracy.
You can just add a photon,
draw a dashed line,
and this is your virtual
state if you want.
Or if you look at
Schrodinger's equation,
you have something
which oscillates
at the frequency
of the state, f,
but now you multiply it with an
electric field which oscillates
at the resonance
frequency, and then
you have something
which oscillates
at the sum of the
two frequencies,
and this is exactly what I
indicated with a dashed line.
So that's how you
create, so to speak,
a degeneracy by using the
frequency of the laser
to overcome the
energy splitting,
and the result is that
you have created exactly
this excited state
level structure.
And if you now look
at the ground state,
and our photon is tuned right
between those two continua,
then we have a dark resonance.
And in order to
accomplish this, I'm
not going into any
calculations here,
but you need a sufficiently
strong coupling
laser who can accomplish that.
For instance,
coupling laser which
is stronger than the spontaneous
emission rate or decoherence
rate gamma in the excited state.
So if we now scan
the probe laser
and we look for
transmission, let
me assume for simplicity
that there is no relaxation
between the two ground states.
If the coupling
laser strength is 0,
then we have a
broad feature, which
is simply the single photon
absorption of the probe light.
If we have an infinitesimal
coupling laser strength,
we get a very,
very sharp feature,
and if the coupling laser
is stronger and stronger,
we get a window of transparency,
and the width is given.
The width delta omega
of this central feature
is given by the Rabi frequency
of the coupling laser.
So what are possible
applications?
One is you can design
non-linear materials.
Usually, when you want to have
frequency conversion processes
or optical switches
at one laser beam
affects another
laser beam, you want
a very strong non-linear
response of your medium,
you usually get that if
you go near resonance,
but near resonance, you
have strong absorption.
But now, using the concept
of EIT, you can have both.
You can have the strong
non-linear response
of your medium near resonance
but you suppress absorption,
you get a window of
transparency using EIT.
So you can have near resonant
materials without absorption.
Again, in principle,
I'm not aware
that this has really taken
off in a bigger time.
One would be if you want to do
very sensitive spectroscopy.
Assume you want to
measure one isotope which
has a tiny little
abundance but you
have to observe it against
the background of a very
strong isotope.
If you could switch off the
absorption of the background,
the absorption of
the strong isotope,
you could still see a small
amount of a trace isotope
in the presence of a
strong absorption line.
So sensitive detection
of trace elements.
Questions about that?
I've given you
qualitative pictures
for lasing without
inversion and for EIT.
I want to give it a little
bit more quantitative touch,
not by going through to the
optical Bloch equations which
would be necessary to
describe all features of it,
but at least I want to
give you one picture where
you can derive
and discuss things
in a more quantitative way, and
this is the eigenstate picture.
I've also done here what
I've said several times,
that when we have splittings
between the levels,
we can actually focus
on what really matters,
namely the detunings,
by absorbing the laser
frequency into the
definition of our levels,
and that's what I've done here.
Instead of using levels g, f,
and e, I have levels with g, f,
e, but this is the photon
number in laser field one
and the photon number
in laser field two.
So if all of the photons,
the laser field one and laser
field two, would be resonance
with their respective
transitions, then all
those three levels
would be degenerate.
But now in the
three level system,
they're not degenerate
only because we
have a relative detuning
delta, detuning small delta
from the Raman resonance, and
we have a detuning peak delta,
which is sort the common
detuning of the Raman laser
from the excited state levels.
So therefore, if I did
define the Rabi frequencies,
the Rabi frequencies over
2 are gain coefficient,
and the Rabi frequencies
are proportional
to the electric field.
Therefore, they scale
with the photon numbers n
and m in the two laser beams.
If I do that, I have a really
very simple Hamiltonian.
On the diagonal, we
simply have the detuning
of both laser beams
form the excited state.
Here we have the Raman detuning,
and we have two couplings
to the excited state.
One is laser field one,
g1, with n photons,
and the other one is laser
field g2 with m photons.
Any questions about?
Just setting up the
simple equations
which we have done a few times.
Let me focus first
on the simple case
that everything is on resonance.
Then, if everything
is on resonance,
we have the structure
which I've shown here.
You can sort of say you
have three levels, which
are degenerate without
any Rabi frequency,
because the detunings
are all zero,
or all the diagonal is zero.
And then the off diagonal matrix
elements, the Rabi frequencies,
are just spreading the
three levels apart,
and the general
structure of this matrix
is that in the
middle, you always
have a state which is just
a superposition of g and f.
So it's a dark state.
It has no contribution
in the excited state.
And the two outer states
have equal contribution
of the excited state.
So the excited state has
been distributed over the two
outer states, and the
widths of those levels
is therefore gamma over 2.
And we know when
we had two levels
and we were driving them with
a Rabi frequency resonantly,
we had splittings
which were just
given by the Rabi
frequency, and now
the splitting between the
outer level and the dark state
is the quadrature sum of
the two Rabi frequencies.
PROFESSOR: So that's a
very general structure.
I want to go back
to the situation
where one laser
is a probe laser.
Let's assume this is
our laser beam which
wants to go through
the brick wall,
and the other laser has
to prepare the system.
Let me discuss the limit where
the photon number becomes very
small in laser one, the
photon number n goes to unity,
and this is much smaller than m.
So we have the situation
of a weak probe field.
If we have this limit,
then the dark state
has much, much more
amplitude in state g,
and the state g is
almost decoupled.
It's in a trivial way.
The dark state
and the laser beam
is very strongly mixing the
state f and the excited state.
So in this limit, we have
a nice physical situation.
I should actually
point out that you
can solve most of those
situations for three level
systems analytically.
It's just those explanations
get long and are not
very transparent.
So what I'm trying
here in the classroom,
I try to pick certain examples--
weak probe field, resonance--
where we can easily understand
the new features which
happen in the system.
So the situation we
have now prepared
is we have our dark
state, which is level g,
we said we have only one
photon in our probe beam,
and we have lots and lots of
photons in the coupling laser
which couples the other ground
state, f, to the excited state,
e.
So we have the structure that
we have now two states which
have half of the widths
of the excited state,
and they are both bright.
We can call one
the bright state 1
and the other the
bright state 2.
The splitting is related
to the Rabi frequency.
Let me just call it delta bar.
This is now the level
structure which we have,
and what I want to now
emphasize in this picture
is the phenomenon
of interference.
We've talked about
interference of amplitudes,
but now I want to
take the system
and show you how we
get now interference
when we send one probe
photon through the system.
What we can now formulate
is a scattering problem.
We have one photon in our
probe beam in a special mode,
but then, all the other
modes are unoccupied.
And when we are asking, does
the probe photon get absorbed?
Does the weak laser beam
get stuck in the brick wall?
We are actually are
asking if it is possible
that we scatter the
photon out of the mode
and it gets absorbed.
But you know absorption
is actually always
a two photon process involves
spontaneous emission,
and we have emitted the
photon into another mode.
The scattering problem
is a two photon process,
and the matrix element
needs an intermediate state,
but now we have two.
We start with one photon, we
have the light atom coupling,
we can go through
bright state 1.
From bright state 1, we have
the light atom coupling again,
and eventually, we go
back to the ground state
without four photon.
And here we have a detuning.
Let's assume we
are halfway detuned
between the two bright states.
And then we have a
second amplitude,
and it's indistinguishable.
We have a Feynman
double slit experiment,
and everything here is
the same except that we
scatter through bright state 2.
This matrix element,
when it vanishes,
this is now the condition
of electromagnetically
induced transparency.
But we want to now
understand what happens
when we detune the probe laser.
So we have set up the system
with a strong control laser,
we have completely mixed the
ground state f with the excited
state, and now we want to
ask, can a weak probe laser
go through the brick wall
How much of the probe laser
is absorbed?
So what we want
to understand now,
and this is a new feature
I want to discuss now,
what happens when we detune
the probe laser by delta?
Well, it's clear, and I just
wanted to show you the formula.
We had two detunings here, and
if we detune the probe laser
by delta, that would mean now
that those denominators are
no longer opposite but equal.
In one case, we add delta.
In the other case,
we subtract delta.
And therefore, we have no
longer the cancellation
of the two amplitudes
and we have
the scattering of the photon.
This is sort of the
framework, and I
want to show you now
several examples.
I want to show you examples
of a probe absorption spectra.
It's more a little
bit of show and tell.
I want to show you the result
if you would work that out.
It's pretty interesting.
So first, I want to discuss
the case where the coupling
laser is really in resonance.
We are near the one
photon resonance.
Let me assume first that the
Rabi frequency of the coupling
laser is much, much
larger than gamma.
Then if you look at
the probe transmission,
we have the situation
that we know
when we are right
here in the middle,
we have a window
of transparency,
but if we detune by the
Rabi frequency over two,
we hit the bright state 1, and
if we detune in the opposite,
we hit the bright state 2.
And the splitting in this
situation, delta bar,
is nothing else than the
Rabi frequency omega 2.
So what we have is we have
the detuning in between,
and we know already here
is our special point,
and that's what
we have discussed
for long, electromagnetically
induced transparency.
The two bright states
are at plus and minus
half the Rabi frequency
of the coupling laser.
We know that we have very
strong absorption here.
What you get is sort
of broad feature.
But this was a situation when we
drive the system very strongly.
I now want to discuss the case
that the coupling laser is
much weaker than gamma.
Then the splitting between
the two bright states
was the Rabi frequency,
but the width is gamma,
so then the two bright
states pretty much merge
into one continuum
feature of width gamma.
For that situation, we have a
broad feature of absorption,
which is on the order
of gamma, or if you
have an opaque
medium, of course,
you put the
absorption coefficient
into the exponent of
an exponential function
and you get a blackout
which is wider than gamma.
But then we have our
phenomenon of EIT,
but the width of this feature
is now much smaller than gamma.
So what we have here
in those two situations
where the lasers are close
to resonance with the excited
level, we have the situation
that the strong absorption
feature due to
the bright states,
either one strong feature of
width gamma or two features
here, those broad, similar
photon absorption features,
they really overlap with
our window of transparency.
And what I find very insightful
is now to discuss the situation
where we separate the two, and
I want to show you what happens.
It gives a very
interesting profile.
So what we want to discuss now
are the famous Fano profiles,
and I want to discuss two
photon absorption features.
We have discussed the case
where the one photon detuning.
We want to go now to a large
one photon detuning delta 2,
and the new feature
now is that this
will separate the window
of electromagnetically
induced transparency from the
broad absorption features.
Let me just draw a
diagram of the states.
As usual, we have our two
states in a lambda transition, g
and f.
We have this continuum
of the excited state,
but now, and this is what often
is done in the experiment,
you're not using Raman
lasers which are in resonance
with the excited state.
You're using Raman lasers--
here is the strong
coupling lasers--
which are far detuned.
So here we have a detuning
for laser two called gamma 2.
The Rabi frequency is omega 2.
Here we have a weak probe laser
omega 1, and the detuning.
Let's call it gamma 1.
So in order to keep
the situation simple,
we use a weak probe laser.
Omega 1 is small.
And our Raman detuning
delta is the difference
between the two single
photons detuning,
capital delta 2 minus delta 1.
For these situations, there
are nice analytic expressions,
and together with
the class notes,
I will post a
wonderfully clear paper
by [? Lunis ?] and [INAUDIBLE]
where the two authors discuss
this situation.
Let's just figure out what are
the features in the system.
Let's just go through
different situations.
One is if the Raman
detuning is zero,
we should always
get the phenomenon
of electromagnetically
induced transparency.
If we don't have
any coupling, then
we simply have a
two level system,
and if we tune omega
1 into resonance,
we get simple single
photon absorption.
So if we look at the
system of the three levels
and we are asking what are
now the relevant processes,
one limit is, of course,
the trivial limit
that we have single
photon absorption.
This is, of course,
a trivial case.
Let's now go to the
more interesting case
that we have a coupling laser.
What happens now?
We have our two states.
The excited state is
coupled with the laser
and Rabi frequency omega 2.
Now we know that the laser omega
2, if it is not on resonance,
will give us an AC Stark shift.
This AC Stark shift, we've gone
through that several times.
It's the matrix element
or Rabi frequency squared
divided by the detuning.
If we now bring in
the probe laser,
what are the features we expect?
Well, there are two features.
One is we've just discussed
the trivial case above.
If we tune the probe laser
into resonance with the excited
state, we have single
photon absorption.
We get a broad feature.
It's almost like in
the two level system.
But in contrast to the case
I just discussed above,
the excited state level e
has now an AC Stark shift
so the resonance is shifted.
That's now becoming
a four photon process
because we need
two photons going
up and down with
a coupling laser
to create the AC Stark shift.
And now we have a laser
from the probe beam
and the photon is scattered,
so it's a four photon process
and it will give us a
broad resonance which
is now AC stack shifted.
But in addition, we
have a resonance,
which is the Raman resonance.
When the Raman detuning
is zero, then we
absorb from the
probe laser and we
emit in a stimulated way
with the coupling laser,
and we have a stimulated
two photon transition.
Now, what is the width of
this stimulated two photon
transition?
Well, we go from a
stable ground state to--
I wanted to say another
stable ground state,
but this other
stable ground state
is now scattering photons.
So because of the presence
of a strong coupling laser,
you have broadened this
level f by photon scattering.
You interrupt the
coherent time evolution
by scattering photons,
and the photon scattering
happens in perturbation
theory by the amplitude to be
in the excited state
squared times gamma.
The scattering rate,
gamma scattering,
is Rabi frequency
divided by detuning.
This is the amplitude to
be in the excited state.
We square that, and then
we multiply with gamma,
and if I can trust
my notes, it's
a factor of two, which I
don't want to discuss further.
This is a quantitative argument.
The analytic expressions
are in the reference
I've given to you.
So the situation which
we have right now
can be in a very powerful
way summarized as follows.
We have our ground
state, we have
two continua we can couple to.
We can couple to the
excited state which
has a width, gamma,
through a single photon,
but there is the AC Stark shift.
Or we can couple through a
two photon Raman transition
to the state f, but the
width is much, much smaller
because it is only the
scattering rate due
to the off resonant
coupling laser.
Let me just write that down
because I said a lot of things.
So g couples now.
When we detune the
probe laser, we
can be in resonance
with this feature
and we can be in resonance
with that feature
to a narrow and
wide excited state.
One excited state, of
course, is the state f,
but the coupling laser puts
some character of the excited
states into the state f.
And the most important
thing now is the following.
This is the theme I've
emphasized again and again when
we discussed three
level systems.
Those two states have
a width, and the width
means they spontaneously
emit light,
but they emit light
into the same continuum.
So if you start in
the ground state,
your probe laser has a photon
and the photon gets scattered.
You do not know through which
channel it has been scattered.
So in general,
and this is as far
as I want to push it in this
class, in three level system,
we have now the interference
between those two continua.
One is narrow and one is wide.
Let me just write that down
because this is important,
but both excited states
couple to the same continuum.
And by continuum,
I mean the vacuum
of all empty states where
photons can be scattered,
and this is the condition
for interference.
And this is, of
course, what gives rise
to electromagnetically
induced transparency.
I'll take your
questions, but let
me first give you
a drawing which
may illustrate, or summarize,
what I've just said.
So what we try to
understand is what happens
when we detune the probe laser.
Until now, we had always the
EIT feature, the EIT window,
was completely overlapping
with the one photon resonance,
but now, because the
coupling laser has
a detuning of gamma 2, we have
to use with the probe laser.
I have to trace back how
the detunings are defined.
The Raman detuning was big
delta 2 minus big delta 1.
If the detuning delta
is chosen to be delta 2,
we have the simple situation
that we go from the ground
state right to
the excited state,
and we have the feature
which has a width of gamma.
This is what you would call
the single photon resonance.
It is the single
photon resonance.
It is due by resonantly
coupling into this continuum,
and the only feature
of the coupling laser
is that there's an
AC Stark shift to it.
Single normal resonance, almost
like in a two level system,
but the only addition
is the AC Stark effect.
Now we have a second feature,
which can be very sharp.
This is when we do the
two photon Raman process
into the other ground state.
Due to photon scattering,
this resonance
has a width of gamma
scattering, and the position
is not at zero at the
naked Raman resonance.
It also has an AC Stark shift
because the coupling laser
does an AC Stark shift to both
the excited and the ground
state.
The coupling laser,
the AC Stark shift,
pushes ground and excited
state in opposite directions.
So therefore, we find
that at the Rabi frequency
of the coupling laser
divided by gamma over 2.
The name of this feature is
the two photon Raman resonance
plus the AC Stark shift,
which actually means
it's a four photon process.
The question is now, where is
the electromagnetically induced
transparency?
We have introduced now
specifically the absorption
feature.
We have identified a one
photon absorption feature
plus AC Stark shift, a
two photon absorption
feature plus AC Stark shift,
but where is electromagnetically
introduced transparency?
Here.
Electromagnetically
induced transparency
is always at delta equals 0.
You have to fulfill
the Raman resonance,
and this resonance is not
affected by any AC Stark shift.
It's always at delta equals 0.
So therefore, what that means
is you have two absorption
features, and you would think
these are two Lorentzians,
but they interfere and they go
to exactly 0 at delta equals 0,
and this is our EIT feature.
So there is an interference
effect between a broad feature
and a narrow
feature, and this is
found in many different
parts of spectroscopy,
but you also find it
in nuclear physics
whenever you have a
narrow feature embedded
into continuum.
What we have here is a narrow
feature and a broader feature,
but a narrow feature
and something
which is broader or continuum
is called a Fano resonance.
You actually have
the same situation
when you look at
scattering of atoms.
Many of you are familiar
with Feshbach resonances.
Well, a lot of people call
it Fano Feshbach resonance,
and what you have in a Fano
Feshbach resonance is two atoms
can scatter off each other.
This is the continuum.
This would be your
broad feature.
But then they can also scatter
through a molecular state,
and this is a narrow feature.
And what we've identified
now for electromagnetically
induced transparency
are the two features.
One is the single
photon absorption,
one is the Ramon resonance.
But in general, the concept
is much more general.
You have a narrow feature,
you have a broader feature.
It's responsible for
scattering two atoms
or it's responsible for
scattering a photon,
and once the photon or the
atoms have been scattered,
you have no way of telling
which intermediate state was
involved.
And therefore, you
get interference.
And what I just said,
what is EIT for light
is the zero crossing
of a scattering length
that the atoms do not
scatter off each other
because the two different
processes completely
destructively interfere.
So what I've shown here is
two Lorentzian, two absorption
features.
Let me know re-plot it and
plot the index of refraction
minus 1.
Here was EIT, zero detuning.
We have a sharp feature here
at the two photon resonance,
we have a broad feature here
at the single photon resonance,
and if I now transform
the Lorentzian
into a dispersive feature.
I use freehand, so this
is a dispersive feature
for the broad transition.
The narrow transition
has a much, much sharper
dispersive feature,
and the important part
is now at the EIT,
at the detuning delta
is zero where we have
electromagnetically
induced transparency, we
have an index of refraction
which is exactly one
because it's a dark state,
you have no absorption, you
have no light scattering,
you have no reaction
to the light.
And therefore, the index of
refraction of the material
is like the index of
refraction of the vacuum.
So you have n equals 1.
It looks like a vacuum in
terms of index of refraction.
It looks like a vacuum because
you have no absorption.
But what you have is you
have a large derivative
of the index of refraction
with the frequency detuning,
and that affects, and that's
what I want to tell you now,
the group velocity of light.
So anyway, this is maybe as
far as I want to push it,
and I was actually wondering
if this is a little bit too
complicated to present in class.
But on the other hand,
I think it sort of also
wraps up the course.
We have a three
level system, and we
find a lot of things we have
studied separately before--
two photon Raman feature,
single photon light scattering--
but now they act
together and they
interfere and have
this additional feature
of electromagnetically
induced transparency.
Colin?
STUDENT: So the way you drew the
level diagram, the f, I think,
[INAUDIBLE] state [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Actually, I emphasized that
we have an AC Stark shift,
and what I didn't say
when I discussed it here
that the AC Stark shift
pushes this level down
and pushes the other level up.
But since we are talking
about a very broad resonance
in the excited state, for
all practical matters,
the AC Stark shift
doesn't matter,
whereas for the narrow
Raman resonance,
the AC Stark shift is important.
STUDENT: Also, you
showed on the plot
that the shift of the
excited state [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
Thanks.
So the AC Stark shift
for that detuning
would shift this level up and
would shift this level down.
What's the second question?
STUDENT: You drew on the plot--
PROFESSOR: This one?
STUDENT: That one.
That the shift of
the excited state
was much higher than the
shift of the ground state.
PROFESSOR: You mean
those two shifts?
STUDENT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: We have to
now do the bookkeeping.
We have assumed that
the coupling laser has
a large detuning,
the coupling laser
is very far away from resonance.
And if you want to
hit the excited state,
we know we need a Raman
resonance, which is delta 2,
but the Raman resonance,
capital delta 2,
means that we are smack
on the single photon
resonance for the probe laser.
So this feature is pretty
much we take the ground state
and go exactly to the excited
state with a single photon.
There is an AC
Stark shift involved
but it's not relevant here,
whereas the other feature is
the two photon Raman feature.
And the one thing I wanted
to point out in this context
is that there is
actually a small energy
splitting between the two photon
Raman feature by the AC Stark
effect, whereas the
EIT feature always
happens at Raman
resonance delta equals 0.
Because, just to
emphasize that, delta
equals 0 is really you induce
a coherence between g and f.
It's a dark state,
and when you have
a dark state in
that situation, you
don't have an AC Stark effect.
So the EIT feature
is at delta equals 0,
whereas the photon scattering
features, they suffer,
or they experience--
it may not be negative to
suffer an AC Stark shift,
but they experience
an AC Stark shift.
Further questions?
Yes?
STUDENT: Can we
somehow relate this
to Doppler free spectroscopy?
PROFESSOR: Can we relate that
Actually, I don't
think so because I
would say for the
whole discussion here,
let's assume we have an atom
which has infinite mass, which
is not moving at all.
We're really talking
about internal coherences.
However, and that's
where it becomes related,
if you look at very,
very narrow features
as a function of detuning
then, of course, Doppler shifts
play a role, and if you
have very, very, very
narrow features, you become
sensitive to very, very, very
small velocities,
and therefore, you
have an opportunity to cool.
So if you can distinguish
spectroscopically
an atom which moves a tiny
little bit and an atom which
stands still, if you
can, by a narrow line,
distinguish the two,
then you can actually
laser cool this atom.
The EIT feature can give you
extremely high resolution.
I'm not discussing it here.
I've discussed the
phenomenon of EIT, which is
coherent population trapping.
But there is an extension, which
is VSCPT, Velocity Selective
Coherent Population Trapping,
and VSCPT was a powerful method
to cool atoms below
the recoil limit,
but I've not connected anything
of coherent population trapping
with the Doppler shift.
So for all this
discussion, please
assume the atom is not moving.
Other questions?
Then let me just say a
few words about the fact
that we have a large derivative
of the index of refraction,
and this, of course,
is used for generating
what is called slow light.
The group velocity of light
is the speed of light,
but then it has a
denominator which
is the derivative of
the index of refraction
with respect to frequency.
Towards the end of
the last century,
there were predictions that
electromagnetically induced
transparency would give you
very sharp features which can
be used for very slow light.
And what eventually triggered
major developments in the field
was this landmark
paper by Lene Hau where
she used the Bose-Einstein
condensate to eliminate
all kinds of Doppler broadening.
There are other tricks
how you can eliminate it,
but this was the
most powerful way
to just take a Bose-Einstein
condensate where
atoms have no thermal velocity
and, in this research,
she was able to show
that light propagated
at the speed of a bicycle.
So it was a dramatic reduction
of the speed of light,
and this showed the
true potential of EIT.
There have been
other demonstrations
before where light has been
slowed by a factor of 100
or a few hundred,
but eventually,
combining that with a
Doppler-less feature
because the atoms
don't move in a BEC
created a dramatic effect.
So we have now two
ways how we can get
a large derivative, dn d omega.
I've discussed here
the general case
that we have a narrow feature,
a broad feature, because we
have the coupling light
detuned from the excited state,
but let me just point out that
even if you have the coupling
light on resonance, depends
what you really want,
but you can get an even
stronger feature in the index
of refraction versus frequency.
This is now the situation where
we have the strong absorption
feature, but then we
have the EIT window.
So we have this superposition
of a positive Lorentzian
and a negative
Lorentzian, and if I now
run it through my
Kramers-Kronig calculator
and I take the
dispersive shape, I
can sort of do it for the
broad feature in this way
and for the narrow
feature in this way,
and now you have
to add up the two.
And what you realize
is at this point,
you have a huge dn d omega.
What I'm plotting here is on
the left side, the absorption
of the Lorentzian, and you
can regard this sharp notch
as a second Lorentzian.
So you have the positive
Lorentzian, negative
Lorentzian, and then you
take the dispersive features
and you add them up
with the correct sign.
So whether you're realizing now
for quite a general situation
where you have single photon
detuning, which I discussed
before, or whether you're on
the single photon resonance,
you can have extremely
sharp features.
So now you can take
it to the next level.
You have a light pulse
which enters a medium,
and now the light pulse slowly
moves through the medium.
But while the light pulse
moves through the medium,
you reduce the strength
of the coupling laser.
What happens?
So you do now an adiabatic
change of your system.
You do an adiabatic change
of the control field
omega 2 while the probe
pulse is in the medium.
Well, that means that under
idealized assumptions which
we've discussed, this
feature gets narrower
and narrower and narrower.
If omega 2 goes to 0, the
strength of the control field,
this feature becomes
infinitesimally narrow.
And therefore, this feature
becomes infinitely sharp,
and that means that the
group velocity goes to zero.
This is now in
the popular press,
it's called stopped
light or frozen light
because the light has
come to a standstill.
What really happens
is the following.
We have our coupling
laser, omega 2,
and we have our
probe laser, omega 1.
When we do what I just said is
that omega 2 goes through zero,
then the dark state originally,
for very strong omega 2,
remember the dark state was g?
But now if we let
omega 2 go to zero,
the dark state will become f.
And that means that in a way,
every photon in the probe pulse
has now pumped an atom from
g through two photon Raman
process into f.
So therefore, what it
means to stop light
or to freeze light means simply
that the photons of the laser
have turned into an atomic
excitation where the excitation
is now the state, f.
In other words, you
have written the photon.
The photon has now put the
atom into a different hyperfine
state.
So if this is done
adiabatically,
and I can't do full
justice in this course,
but this means that
the light is coherently
converted into the atomic--
when I say "coherently"
say "into population," I
mean all the quantum
phases, everything which
was in the quantum nature of the
light has now been converted,
has been written
into the state, f.
This is often called, because
g and f are hyperfine states,
this means that
you have coherently
converted the photon or
the electromagnetic wave
in the probe beam into
a spin wave or a magnon.
Anyway, I just want to
show you the analogy.
The fact that you can put the
quantum information of light
into an atomic state
and back and forth,
we've discussed that when we
had the situation of cavity QED.
We prepared a superposition
of ground and excited state
and exactly the same quantum
state which we had in the atom
we later found in the
cavity as a superposition
of the zero photon and
the one photon state.
So from those general concepts,
it should be clear to you
that it is possible
to coherently
transform a quantum
state from light to atoms
and back to light.
And here you see the
different realization.
We have a quantum state of
the photon in the probe laser,
and we can now describe
the excitations
in the system in a
parametrized way.
What it means is for
the strong probe laser,
for the strong coupling laser,
the excitation in the system
travels as a photon
in the field one,
but when you reduce the
coupling in the coupling laser,
the excitation becomes
less and less photon-like.
It becomes more and more
magnon-like, spin wave like.
And the moment you reduce the
power in the coupling laser
to zero, what used
to be an excitation
in the electromagnetic field has
now been termed adiabatically
into a spin excitation.
Coherence has been written
into the hyperfine states
or your atoms, g and f.
All this is done coherently,
and therefore reversibly.
You can read out the information
by simply time reversing
the process.
You ramp up again
the coupling laser,
and that adiabatically turns
the spin excitation back
into an excitation of the
electromagnetic field.
Any questions?
Well, we have
three minutes left,
but I'm not getting
started with superradiance.
We have one more
topic left, and this
will be the topic on
Wednesday, decay superradiance,
and this is when we discuss the
phenomenon of coherence where
we have coherence not only in
one atom between two or three
levels.
We will then
discuss on Wednesday
if we have coherence
between many atoms,
and this at the heart
of superradiance.
OK.
See you on Wednesday.